[Musique]
bonjour bassem alors un vote de
confiance passé tard dans la nuit mais
qui divise la classe politique
tunisienne ce remaniement ne semble pas
faire l'unanimité ni calmer les tensions
bonjour olivier bonjour mes délits
effectivement un vote de confiance qui
est passée très tard dans la nuit qui
était censée les un petit peu la
situation surtout la colère des
manifestants
c'est l'effet inverse qui s'est passé
dans la mesure où les ministres qui
allait proposer le premier ministre mais
chichi ont été largement orientée par le
parti islamiste ennahda le président de
la république déjà rémy certaines
réticences concernant ce choix de
ministres il a jugé que certains étaient
corrompus il a même reconnu qu'ils
n'avaient pas cette femme dans ce le
nouveau gouvernement de vives tensions
au sein même de l'assemblée nationale
tard le soir certains députés de
l'opposition sont même montés au créneau
il avait déclaré qu'ils pourraient
rejoindre les manifestants autour du
parlement et surtout en tunisie en
général pour pouvoir contester le
gouvernement et surtout cette politique
largement influencée par le parti
ennahdha c'est les arguments qui
revenait très souvent et les cimes
augmentent pendant les manifestations
le parti islamiste ennahda mme pointé du
doigt rendu un responsable de la
situation chaotique et économique du
pays
hier soir on a reçu une information une
alerte qui a été confirmée par la
présidence de la république
la présente à lui qui aurait reçu un
courrier pour y est empoisonné avec une
substance toxique est largement
mordelles destinée au président de la
république la présence d'un public
heureusement pas eu accès à ce courrier
elle n'a pas ouvert la personne qui l'a
offert est une personne du personnel du
palais de carthage qui va pas très bien
et en attendant les services de
renseignement ouvert une enquête pour
savoir d'où venait ce courrier est pour
le moment ce choix du premier ministre
mais si china fait que réaliser elle les
tensions et c'est toujours aussi tendues
que ce soit dans la capitale dans le
reste du pays
et puisqu'un de nouvelles manifestations
bassam son imprévus effectivement mais
de nouvelles manifestations sont prévues
elles ont commencé depuis le 14 janvier
déjà beaucoup d'appels à manifester sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment sur
facebook
ce qui a changé depuis hier c'est que
plus aucun appel à manifester n'est
envoyée sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment facebook à la police se semble
avoir réprimé à toute personne qui en
seraient les appels à manifester
beaucoup d'arrestations depuis 14
janvier dernier on a compté plus de 1300
beaucoup de mineurs entre 14 dès 14 ans
et puisse aller jusqu'à 25 30 ans des
militants qui sont vraiment décidés à en
découdre avec la police et faire tomber
tout ce système politique jugée aux
corrompus et qui ne répond pas
favorablement à leurs revendications
depuis plus de dix ans certains acquis
vont vite et quand même gagné notamment
sa liberté d'expression mais cette
liberté d'expression laquelle le seul
acquis qu'elle est au pyla la révolution
semble être remise en question c'est ce
qu'ont annoncé coup demande de la
société civique sont montés au créneau
en disant que traquer ces personnes là
qui appellent à manifester est une
collation de la liberté d'expression
donc on ne peut plus voir quand est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des manifestations
tout sera fait par le bouche à oreille
mais c'est que l'on peut dire et savoir
c'est que le mouvement contestataire
continuera ce soit dans la capitale ou
dans le reste de la tunisie
merci beaucoup bassam pour toutes ces
précisions ben hassen chébili envoyé
spécial à tunis pour rt france